well you know George Washington said one
of the most important qualities for a
society to have a civility and what does
civility mean the founding fathers did
not agree on a lot of stuff I mean
Madison didn't agree with with you know
Hamilton and and and and Jefferson they
were very much at odds about how to go
forward with this republic but they
talked it out they compromised nobody
nobody got violent besides Aaron Burr
and [ __ ] Hamilton at it but for the
most part they compromised they talked
and George Washington said civility the
ability to listen to the other side but
even then when you don't agree with them
and put your ideas together that's how
you move things forward and we just
don't have that anymore you just don't
have it I think that's a really good
point and that's what bothers me the
most about this is not not that they're
not correct that there's some real
problems it's the way everybody's going
about it that makes me say like do you
understand what happens when you yell at
people like you can't just push people
there's people that don't understand
violent consequences there's people that
don't understand conflict and they don't
know how to mitigate it and they don't
know how to like be calm and how to
figure their way through a situation
there's dangerous levels of aggression
that get reached when you have like an
Tifa feuding with these people that are
trying to do some sort of a speech
somewhere and there's the supporters of
the speech and then there's an Tifa and
everybody's getting together and
screaming and there's fire and by clocks
and people beating the [ __ ] out of each
other
all this stuff there's there's plenty of
videos of this are happening this this
doesn't have to end here okay this
wasn't here five years ago understand
this that this could escalate in five
years to be significantly worse than it
is now and me as a person who I don't
want violence around me I I see that
[ __ ] coming and I go oh these guys are
fighting let's get the [ __ ] out yeah you
don't want to go get close to them I
hope you catch a stray bullet and I see
that the problem is that 5-10 years like
it is the problems that cop that comes
to you yes
I mean it's unnecessary it's not how we
should communicate with each other you
know and I think there's also people
that are emboldened by movements right
they get it they become a part of a
movement
and then they want to do something to
commit to that movement it's very
similar to joining a [ __ ] militia
it's very similar to joining a
resistance me it makes it easier social
media isn't made it easier to find your
tribe surround yourself with people who
see the world exactly like you do and
organize and attack the other shot they
sit with social media that's what makes
Isis kind of so yeah so violent and also
so scary is because social media the
first ones kind of mastered social media
my bigger worry is also the fact that
people can't even agree on the validity
of their sources so if I say well you
know according to the United Nations or
the Bureau of Labor and Statistics
and you go that's [ __ ] so now I
can't even get off the ground because
it's too much of right so I'm going to
if I go to mainstream sources you go
that's mainstream and that's
bullshitting they're brought up by
corporations they have energy I can't
even have well here's something that I'm
trying to get better at and I've worked
on it a lot I try really hard to not be
connected to whatever I believe it
mm-hm and I try to not try to win a
conversation those are two very
important things behind it yes but I'm
trying harder than I've ever tried in my
life and I've been on a path trying to
do this for years now and getting better
at it because of just listening to
podcasts listen and having podcasts and
having conflicts with people and trying
to figure out why I had those conflicts
and how much of it was my fault how much
of it could have prevented how much who
I could have done a better job as a host
or as a person who's trying to relay the
information and through time I have
tried my hardest and it's something I
concentrate on all the time to not be
connected to my ideas to argue them if I
feel like there's merit but argue the
merit argue my connection your emotions
emotional connection so when someone
does that I get I get exhausted now
because I know where it's gone like
we're gonna waste a lot of time with
this because you're not willing to even
think about the possibility to I said to
Theresa those podcasts they were Jordin
Peterson I said do you feel like you're
winning this debate because at this
point he'd become so famous and he said
I don't want to win this because I'm
going to create resentful people who
feel like resentful losers that's not
yes that's not the point the point is to
figure out a way to present ideas so
that they are
accessible to the people whose minds I'm
trying to change this is exactly what he
said about Trump supporters he said if
you disagree with Trump supporters don't
insult them make them feel like they're
losers exactly know what that doesn't
make anybody feel good and you what I'm
not true he also says how do you think
they're going to react to that you think
they're just gonna give in to you and
he's a clinical psychologist so you
understand how he understands how human
brains work we do that immediately what
do we say about Trump supporters a lot
of people this I really think they're
racists they're oxes they're they're
sexist transphobic they're they're
Mexican haters and all this stuff
whereas maybe the Left presented an
alternative that was unacceptable to
them they didn't like this con man or
this guy was an egotist but they were
like let's give it a shot right I have
300 bucks in the bank I got no other
options there's also that give people
the benefit of the doubt most people are
not [ __ ] yeah there's there's both
of those things and there's some people
that are asked sure that's part of the
problem is that you run it enough of
those those hurt your feelings and you
think oh all Trump supporters are
[ __ ] Dority though right but that's
I feel like it's all negativity bias -
it is also something where our brains we
gravitate towards if you have a thousand
comments and 900 over positive you'll
see the one that ya know if you have 900
and you have a hundred that are negative
you're [ __ ] super fun you're gonna
read a hundred negative like you'll have
a million right or wrong think about how
amazing that is that you have 90 percent
positive in this crazy world oh I know
so things all good right so if you have
but your mind looks like you know your
mind goes towards the name yeah but what
I'm saying is that the numbers as they
expand they get more and more ridiculous
so if you have a podcast the podcast
gets a million downloads and you get a
hundred thousand negative comments and
nine hundred thousand positives have you
look this is exhaustive have you looked
at how many people alcohol kills versus
guns for example oh you know I'm saying
I mean but nobody's talking about
banning alcohol you could really go into
all these details right there well the
severity expensive obesity shortened
lives because of poor diet tells way
more people in terrorism it kills a lot
of [ __ ] people